I grew up with the notion that anything
was possible my dad was a firm believer
in aspiring to the best of your ability
and even unimaginable realities
[Music]
the story of Hello tomorrow is so
personal in so many ways it's an
imagined world that's talking about the
American aspirational dream
my dad was a Salesman
I grew up in a house where the closet
was filled with products that were
floating through my childhood inflatable
ice chest hat umbrellas none of which
ever had any success but every single
one of them was going to be the key to
our future
one of the things that you try to do as
an actor is use somebody close to you as
a reference point for a character
to try to get inside the head of your
father has been a froth in so many ways
when I think back about my father now
always like keep your chin up it was
because there was repeated rejection
it's a desperate position to be in
we live with Miracles that are
fingertips we fly into the Stars we
split atoms we've got robots taking out
the trash why
are we all still waiting to live our
dreams
like all people we go through periods of
our life where hope is uh you know sand
in the palm of your hand
there is a great veneer over these
gadgets what they're really doing is
giving somebody an opportunity to hope
for a better future
and my dad never gave up on that there's
something so romantic about that sense
of unbridled unabashed hopefulness I've
had some incredibly fortunate
opportunities in my career and this
certainly is up there with them
you get the Dream On A Better Tomorrow
or you can have it all
[Music]